this is happening all over the country
as you know and there's a reason for it
over the weekend most recently doubtless
you've heard of this city officials
announced their plan to remove the
statue of Teddy Roosevelt from outside
New York's Museum of Natural History the
bronze statue has stood there in the
Theodore Roosevelt rotunda facing
Central Park since before the Second
World War
soon it will be gone people who erected
that statue 80 years ago would be
confused by this no doubt they did not
consider Teddy Roosevelt a controversial
figure in fact Roosevelt was the most
popular president in American history he
was also the most American president no
other country could have produced Teddy
Roosevelt Roosevelt's virtues mirrored
the values of America he was physically
brave he was profoundly literate highly
self disciplined and amazingly energetic
while still a college student Roosevelt
wrote a two-volume history of the war of
1812 that is still in print today you
can buy it on Amazon he was the youngest
president in our history he saved our
economy from corporate monopolies and by
doing that he made the American middle
class possible he created the National
Park secret the Panama Canal the Food
and Drug Administration and then he kept
going the list of Teddy Roosevelt's
achievements fills entire shelves of
biographies those are in addition to the
more than 40 books he wrote himself on
topics ranging from oliver cromwell to
cattle ranching to social justice
personally roosevelt was a famously
decent man in 1901 he invited his friend
Booker T Washington to dinner no African
American had ever eaten in the White
House Democrats roared with rage at the
idea for the crime of having a meal with
a black man they attacked Teddy
Roosevelt and his wife for the rest of
their lives but Roosevelt never bowed he
gave the finger to the mob and he
continued cheerfully on Teddy Roosevelt
was a hero to millions of Americans he
still is that's precisely why they're
tearing down his statue they know that
if they can force you to watch as they
topple your heroes they have won there
is nothing they can't do next they can
decide how you raise your children how
you vote what you're allowed to believe
once they've humiliated you they can
control you
and that's why across the country mobs
are tearing down America's monuments in
the cities of Richmond in st. Paul
Minnesota they've torn down statues of
Christopher Columbus they did this
in Boston Boston's mayor now says it's
time to remove a statue of Abraham
Lincoln
the man who freed the slaves it's racist
in Dallas they pulled a Texas Ranger
statue out of the airport after more
than 50 years in Dearborn Michigan they
toppled the statue of the former mayor
they did the same thing in Philadelphia
in Nashville they pulled down a statue
of a former US senator same in Albany in
Oregon Thomas Jefferson and George
Washington were torn down in San
Francisco the mob demolished statues of
ulysses s grant who nibiru Serra and
Francis Scott Key on the pedestal of the
key monument they spray-painted kill the
colonizers and kill whitey just in case
you missed the point one thing all of
these Americans now canceled have in
common not one of them fought for the
Confederacy pulling down their statues
had nothing to do with the Civil War at
least not the first Civil War the one
that took place 150 years ago Democrats
understand that very well and they
support all of it in every place where
the mob has destroyed public monuments
Democratic leaders have backed them as
they did it but at the same time and you
should know this so have many
Republicans last week a mob in downtown
Washington DC decided to tear down a
statue of a man called Albert Pike Pike
was famous as a journalist and a poet
and later as a prominent freemason for
less than a year from late November of
1861 to mid July of 1862 Pike served in
the Confederate Army Pike was later
arrested for treason against the
Confederacy and he faced execution for
that but in the end it didn't save him
from the mob they set fire to Pike's
effigy as it lay on the ground at least
one prominent conservative tweeted his
approval of this Republicans in Congress
said nothing at all and they could have
Pike's now destroyed statue is owned by
the National Park Service it's federal
property tearing it down was a federal
crime but no one in Washington even
considered enforcing that law Kevin
McCarthy of California the top
Republican in the House was not in a
position to say much of anything
McCarthy has endorsed the removal of
statues that the left has designated as
racist last week as violent mobs roamed
the country destroying public property
Kevin McCarthy refused to acknowledge it
on his official Twitter account on
Wednesday McCarthy did manage to send a
very emphatic tweet
calling for sanctions against Syria
quote to hold the Assad regime
responsible for its atrocities electric
Republicans almost all of them are no
hurry to stop the disorder they appear
to believe what we're watching is a
version of the Rodney King riots from
1992 people saw an upsetting video on
the internet they're angry and that's
understandable but they'll calm down
soon and we can get back to cutting
capital gains taxes and sanctioning the
Charla Saad that's the review of it they
are wrong this is not a momentary civil
disturbance this is a serious and highly
organized political movement it is not
superficial it is deep and profound it
has vast ambitions it is insidious it
will grow its goal is to end liberal
democracy and challenge Western
civilization itself this is an
ideological movement the idea is that
few late-- have incubated for decades on
college campuses we paid for all of it
by the way the rest of us were so
thrilled that our kids got into Duke
that we decided to ignore what duke was
actually teaching them and has continued
to send big checks that was a mistake it
was when the gravest mistakes we've ever
made
we didn't appreciate the stakes involved
at the time and as a result of that we
became easy marks for their lives even
now so many of us continue to pretend
that this is about police brutality's
but the death of a man called George
Floyd in Minneapolis
we still imagine we can fix it by
regulating chokeholds or spending more
on de-escalation training we are too
literal or too good-hearted to
understand what's really happening our
decency is the mobs main weapon against
us we have no idea who we're up against
for most people the primary joy in life
is the act of creation making something
good and useful whether it's dinner for
your family or a deck off the back of
your house or a solid day at work the
most profound act of creation of course
is having children new life itself
healthy societies celebrate all of this
they understand that the impulse to
create is how civilizations are built
but they also recognize that there are
forces arrayed against creation and they
vigilantly defend themselves against
those in every society there are those
who seek to destroy they destroy for the
same reason that troubled boys tortured
dogs or shoot house cats
inflicting pain makes them feel powerful
we used to call people like that
antisocial forces they still exist we
just pretend they don't or worse we
excuse their behavior we coddled them we
fund them
Wall Street sends the money in the hope
that they will be destroyed last the
rest of us just look on confused
we don't really know what's happening
but the destroyers know they know
exactly what's going on never in
American history have they been more
emboldened than they are now just this
afternoon around lunchtime an activist
called Shaun King issued the following
demand on Twitter quote all murals and
stained glass windows of white Jesus and
his European mother and their white
friends should also come down they are a
gross form of white supremacy created as
tools of oppression racist propaganda
they should all come down in quote
before you dismissed that idea is absurd
the rantings of some crank on social
media keep in mind that Shaun King is
the most famous black lives lap matter
leader in this country black lives
matter is now more popular than either
major political party so don't be
surprised when they come for your church
why wouldn't they no one is stopping
them the forces of destruction have
grand ambitions it's not just about the
Teddy Roosevelt statue they plan to rule
this country what will happen if they do
well you may imagine that self defense
is your bulwark against chaos in this
country you assume you can always defend
yourself in your family that's a pillar
of our civilization of all Western
civilization's
this woman assumed that - on Wednesday
she was driving through Louisville
Kentucky according to Louisville police
the woman found herself surrounded by
protesters who were blocking the road
they stood in front of her car with a
megaphone she argued with them to let
her pass one of them produced a gun the
woman tried to flee we're showing the
dramatic tape on your screen right now
look at it when the woman stopped at a
red light a block later another
protestor pointed a gun at her again
she hit the gas and made it home alive
on Sunday National Public Radio
published an article about the incident
the headline of that piece quote vehicle
attacks rise as extremists
get protesters in other words for trying
to escape from being murdered NPR called
this woman an extremist who was quote
targeting protesters think about that
and you begin to understand why so few
citizens have tried to stop the mobs as
they pillage our country and see if it
has an own the statues in your cities
parks it doesn't own your city you do
you help pay for it but what would
happen if he tried to defend public
property or even if you tried to defend
your own property you know the answer
you'd be swarmed by federal agents you'd
be Roger stoned with the help and
complicity of CNN and NPR and so many
others
you'd be the criminal there's no
question you've seen this happen before
to a remarkable degree federal law
enforcement is now driven by political
imperatives certain kinds of so-called
hate crimes top the list of priorities
they'll draw the FBI faster than you
could summon the local police to your
house during a home invasion even when
as is so often the case they turn out to
be hoaxes meanwhile actual hate crimes
brutal crimes in which Americans are
gravely injured or ignored completely
they take place on our streets with
shocking regularity the media don't
cover them they often go unpunished
entirely that's not speculation there's
quite a bit of video of it online some
of it very recent we're not going to
show you the clips if you're interested
go to the Twitter feed for the Matt
Walsh blog before Twitter pulls it down
you'll get the point but you already
know laws are not applied equally in
America some victims are considered more
deserving than others despite the fact
for all citizens justice is not blind
never in our lives has this been more
true than it is right now and is very
likely to get worse that's the aim of
this movement of these riots to
overthrow the value the principle of
equality under the law after November
that trend could accelerate dramatically
and by the way we should stop pretending
that this is an election between Donald
Trump and Joe Biden there is no Joe
Biden the Joe Biden you remembered no
longer exists the babbling husk you see
may have the same name and similar
features but behind the mask there is
nothing but a jumbled collection of
talking points from the early 70s
your record player no malarkey the
candidate has no independent thoughts of
his own he has no core beliefs he is
empty
he is a perfect Trojan horse for the
people who have taken over the
Democratic Party he is perfect their
plan is to ride him to power once there
someone tough and calculating and
purposeful camel Harris probably will
change the country how well they showed
us how for three years they told us that
secret Russian agents had taken over the
US government there was never a single
piece of evidence to show that that was
true in any way it was a hoax and yet it
worked they dominated the country with
that lie and that was their dry run can
we convince millions of people to
believe something that's completely
absurd
yes we can that's what they learned
that's the lesson they'll do it again
this time the Russians will be
Confederate sympathizers or Nazis or
white supremacists or whatever other
name they choose to give to their
political opponents it almost doesn't
matter but once they pick one they will
gin up mass hysteria because that's what
they're good at the media will
collaborate fully because that's their
job and we'll have another witch hunt
once again with the full support of
federal law enforcement and intelligence
agencies and who knows maybe the
military - because the threat is just
that profound a few foolish souls will
attempt to point out the obvious what's
true of course there are racists here as
there are everywhere but overall this is
the least racist country in the history
of the world millions of Africans want
to move here many already have our last
president was black what are you talking
about those people will be silenced
anyone who defies the narrative will be
silenced by that point the category of
hate speech will have expanded to
include anything they don't want to hear
and it will be criminalized a federal
offense you watch if they can tear down
a Lincoln statue because it's racist
they can ban the First Amendment you
don't want to live in a place like that
who can save us from that well as of
right now only Republicans can save us
from that not because they're inherently
virtuous not because they want to they
don't
but because they're the opposition party
to the extent they still have opposition
to anything we have no choice but to ask
for their help the Republican Party is
the only power center left in this
country available to people who dissent
it doesn't matter who you voted for last
time this is not an endorsement of
anyone's policies it's an
acknowledgement of who holds power and
who doesn't and the Republican Party is
the only power center available on
Friday Finn's colonies The Daily Caller
interviewed Donald Trump in the White
House colonies asked the president why
he hasn't sent federal troops to stop
the chaos in cities like Seattle here's
how the president answered quote right
now I think it's great sitting back and
watching this catastrophe end quote
we understand the point he was making
these are liberal cities and they're
destroying themselves their policies
don't work this is what you get when you
vote for liberals but it's still the
wrong answer a president is responsible
for all Americans no matter where they
live for the country itself imagine if
you had a bitter argument with one of
your children the kid runs out of the
house then goes completely off the deep
end it becomes a heroin addict living on
the street but you don't look for him
you don't try and save him instead you
brag that his drug addiction is proof
you were right all along
right now I think it's great sitting
back and watching this catastrophe you
wouldn't say that no good parent would
say that no president should say it
either we need help and we need it right
now these are not protests this is a
totalitarian political movement and
someone needs to save the country from
it